Speaker 1: Arkansas Governor Asa Hutchinson,
a Republican, came out this week and admitted,
oops, I shouldn't have signed a ban on mask
mandates in my state.
Now that covid numbers are going through the
roof again, I messed up is the message that
we got from Arkansas Republican Governor Asa
Hutchinson this week.
Here's a couple of quotes I want to read here.
And this is what Hutchinson said.
Well, I signed it at the time because our
case is we're at a very low point.
I knew it'd be overridden by the legislature
if I didn't sign it.
I already eliminated our statewide Marzook
mandate.
I signed it for those reasons that our cases
were at a low point.
Everything is change now.
And yes, in hindsight, I wish that had not
become law.
So.
Yeah, I did it.
Oops, I wish I hadn't, but, you know, it's
not like I'm in a position of power to do
anything about it.
You are though, OK?
And, hey, it's great that you've come around
and realize you messed up too little, possibly
too late at this point.
He is, of course, now asking the legislature
to at least overturn the part of the law that
doesn't allow school districts to decide whether
to put mass mandates in place.
So at the very least, Asa Hutchinson is out
there begging the Republican controlled legislature,
can you guys at least make it to where school
districts get to make their own decisions
about protecting the kids?
But, folks, this is what happens.
This is why you can't have these reactionaries
as leaders.
They give in to the worst of their constituents,
the people who say that masks are tyranny
or that masks are somehow oppression.
There neither, by the way.
But they signed this law to gain political
points both over in Arkansas, over here in
Florida, because they think it's going to
gain them some political points.
And then, boom, everything blows up and their
hands are essentially tied at this point.
Now, over here in Florida, Rhonda Santurce
could could come out and make the same kind
of statements that Asa Hutchinson has, because
at least Hutchinson had the good sense to
be like, whoa, folks, I messed up so bad.
Of course, he wasn't that extreme with it.
But the Santurce is over here watching again
as we just had a day where 20000 people.
Got diagnosed with covid.
I have family members in the hospital right
now down in South Florida in the ICU.
So this is a personal thing for me, it is
a political thing for me, it does hit close
to home for me.
And de Santos is doubling down, saying, yeah,
Biden, I'm going to stand in your way, I am
not going to comply, I'm not going to listen
to the CDC.
I am not going to let anyone other than me
decide what's best for the millions and millions
of residents here in the state of Florida
that, oh, by the way, are dropping dead because
of my idiotic decisions to say it is.
His poll numbers have also taken a massive
hit because of this.
As I mentioned, the one poll, obviously, he's
trailing his Democratic rival.
That one will change, hopefully for the better.
But his approval rating is now fallen to 43
percent as of this morning.
Now, forty three percent still not horrible,
but when you consider the support that this
guy had, he has dropped by double digits.
In just the last month.
That's how extreme this is, that's how extreme
he is.
And the residents are waking up to it and
they're waking up to it every time another
relative goes into the hospital, they're waking
up to it every time they have to put another
family member in the ground.
It's terrifying and it's horrible that this
is what it's taking some people to finally
wake up and realize that sometimes you have
to put the science over the politics.
But people are starting to see exactly how
dangerous to Santurce policies truly are,
he's not going to pull an Asa Hutchinson,
he's not going to come out and say, I screwed
up.
I regret this.
He's going to continue to double down because
he thinks it's going to help him politically,
even though the numbers show it's doing the
exact opposite.
Unfair and cousins sitting in for David Pakman
today, we'll be
right back.